hey you guys merry christmas happy
holidays and welcome to my christmas
edition of my flickers of fear movie
review show
where i'm actually doing a christmas
movie today this is actually gonna go up
on christmas day or christmas eve if
you're a patron
and this movie this was like a pretty
well like a no-brainer for one that i
wanted to go up on christmas day because
this is actually
a christmas movie in the sense that you
know it's set on christmas eve someone
that's going to a christmas party and
it's also one that uh doesn't really get
talked about all that much and i kind of
feel like it's something of an
underrated gem i actually hadn't heard
of it until fairly recently um i was
going through one of my beloved uh
horror lists like i go to different
blogs and stuff and look for
recommendations for stuff that i might
have missed out on and this was one that
came up on a lot of people's underrated
christmas horror movie lists and stuff
like that and uh so i think that i sat
down and watched it probably like two
years ago and i just i thought it was
great and i was just like oh my god why
why doesn't hardly anybody bring this
movie up it doesn't really get talked
about a lot uh you know even among
christmas horror movies it has started
to kind of filter into some lists more
recently uh but yeah this is a great
great movie and it's called dead end and
it's from 2003. uh don't confuse it
because i know there's a bunch of other
movies called dead end i think even one
of the wrong turn movies is called
something like wrong turned whatever
dead end or whatever it's not that one
uh this is the one from 2003 which has
ray wise and lynn shea in it so if that
doesn't make you want to watch it i
don't know what does because i love
those two you know i mean obviously ray
wise had done you know twin peaks and
stuff like that at this point but i
think this was prior to linshay
becoming kind of more of a horror icon
because of all the you know insidious
movies and all that kind of stuff so and
she's actually fantastic in this
this is a pretty low budget uh film
and it's actually french even though all
the actors in it as far as i know are uh
american or canadian
and uh but the directors of it are
french it was actually written and
directed by jean-baptiste andrea and
fabrice canapa
and um i don't know i don't remember
what else they had done i don't think
fabrice canepas and i think uh she's
only done like a couple more films but i
think sean baptiste andrea has done some
more stuff and i believe he's a novelist
as well
um but this movie this is one of those
things that i love coming across movies
like this and by the way if you want to
watch it uh it's on 2b right now for
free at least as of you know christmas
2021 uh so definitely go check it out
it's really worth a watch i almost want
to say it's like a horror comedy but
it's like a dark comedy um don't go into
it thinking that it's gonna be like jump
scares or it's gonna be super gory or
anything like that it's sort of like a
lot of the gore
in it so i'm just like warning you ahead
of time because i don't want you to
think it's this big bloodbath or
anything like [ __ ] up [ __ ] does happen
but a lot of the gore is more implied
than shown uh there is like a little bit
of violence and stuff but it's not a
bloodbath by any means and it's kind of
more of a twilight zoney kind of vibe
now it does have sort of a twisty twist
end kinda if you've seen a lot of horror
movies i don't think it'll be too hard
to guess where it's going
but
i don't really think that that
diminishes the enjoyment of the movie by
any stretch the imagination i think the
strength of this one
is
uh the character work and the
interaction between the characters which
is good because a movie like this
that is essentially just like one i want
to say like one location it's not
exactly but i'll get into that in a
minute but where it's just kind of like
a very small scale
film where it's just a bunch of people
like together in an enclosed space for
you know for an extended amount of time
and you really need that cast to [ __ ]
nail it um especially with a premise as
kind of like strange or like eerie as
this one and i really think that is the
main thing that really really sells this
movie is the cast of it is just great
and i just love their interactions they
actually really do seem like a horribly
bickering family like
going to grandma's house or whatever and
it's just it's so so good like the way
that it's put together so uh so like i
said i really like discovering horror
movies like this where
the budget of it is obviously really
really small i don't even know how much
this cost to make maybe a couple million
it actually ended up i don't even know
if it got a theatrical release in the us
i'm pretty sure it didn't
but i think what ended up happening was
that it got really good word of mouth i
guess when it came out on dvd and it
ended up making like 77 million dollars
in dvd sales which is kind of a big deal
uh for a movie that wasn't really all
that it didn't really seem to have much
you know marketing or anything like that
behind it and like i said i hadn't heard
of it i didn't hear of it when it came
out it might have gotten a theatrical
release but i don't remember it getting
one uh if it did i certainly didn't see
it back when it came out in 2003 but
this just goes to show
that if you have a good script and a
good concept then have to be the most
original concept in the world because
this isn't i've seen some other movies
that are kind of similar to this but
that's no you know that
what concept is original nowadays it's
like you can put original spins on
things but everything's been done at
this point so you can just kind of like
put your own kind of style to it and
that's pretty much all you can ask for
and that's what this movie does
but it just goes to show you have a
great script you have great actors um
you know and a cool concept and it will
take you a really long way towards
making a really effective really
entertaining uh horror movie and this
definitely has that in spades so uh what
the setup of this movie is
basically it starts pretty much just in
the middle of things it almost and i've
seen a couple other um
reviews say this as well that it almost
seems that it almost kind of seems like
a like a stage play a little bit and it
even kind of like starts in sort of like
the middle of a conversation and i think
that kind of adds to it's a little bit
odd in the sense that it's not like a
standard low-budget american horror
movie you can tell that this wasn't
necessarily an american director um
because it has a little bit of a
different
sort of sensibility to it i guess even
though as i said all the actors are
american and most of them are people
that you will recognize
so the setup of this there's a family uh
which consists of the dad who's played
by ray wise and his name is frank
and his wife uh laura who's played by
lynn shea now they have two older kids
they have a teenage son who looks about
16 ish uh his name's richard and he they
have a grown daughter named marion who
i'm assuming is like in her early 20s
because she says something about being
she seems like she's in grad school or
something like that so she's probably
like in her 20s she's actually played by
alexandra holden who i think was maybe i
kind of want to say she was maybe in one
of the american horror stories things
but i think she's been at some other
movies too like she was in the hot chick
and like some other stuff and uh so and
then then she also her boyfriend brad
who's actually gonna propose to her
although she doesn't know that yet
is also along with them so the three of
them are in the back seat and then you
know mom and dad are in the front and
they are on their way to laura's like
the wife's mom's house like grandson
grandma's house for their traditional uh
christmas
dinner like christmas eve dinner which
they do every year uh they even say like
later on that they've been doing this
for 20 years so this is assuming this is
the 21st year that they're going
now for whatever reason which they get
into it a little bit
the dad frank i guess it's like a really
long drive and he's getting kind of
sleepy and kind of you know dozing off
or whatever and he decides that instead
of taking the interstate uh as they have
done every year for the past two decades
he decides just for a little spice a
little entertainment look keep himself
awake he says he's gonna take this uh
this backwood this back way this
shortcut
and you know if you've seen any horror
movies you know that taking a shortcut
especially one that's kind of like in
the middle of the woods that's never
gonna end well and indeed this does not
end well either
now very very early in the film
ironically even though frank has decided
yeah we're gonna take this back road and
then pretty much all the other family
members have fallen asleep and then he
starts to do doze off as well and he
kind of goes into
uh the other lane like and you know this
other car is like coming at them and
like honks and he has to swerve and uh
the car doesn't wreck you know he is
actually get able to get out of the way
but obviously everybody uh wakes up
now shortly after this they see
they have passed like this cabin and
then um they see this woman
in white and she looks like she's kind
of wounded like she has kind of like a
cut on her on her forehead and she looks
like she's carrying a baby
so uh so he's looking out there in the
woods and he's like i could have sworn i
saw a woman in white out there so this
has like kind of a folklorish you know
vanishing hitchhiker kind of vibe to it
too which i really thought was was a
cool addition
now uh so he's like yeah i just saw her
and they're like well we don't see
anything they're looking out there and
then she comes around to the other side
of the car and he's asking her questions
like you know do you need help you look
like you're hurt or whatever and he's
like hey there was a cabin back there
you know let's put her in the car and
we'll take her back to the cabin and
maybe we can you know get some help or
find somebody there that's where she
came from or whatever so she gets in the
car and they start asking her like hey
where'd you come from you know are you
all right and she really won't answer
them so they just assume that she's been
hurt and that she's in shock or whatever
so at this point uh they get back to
this cabin and they go in there and
there's like nothing in there really
there's just like all these animal
skulls and [ __ ] like that hanging all
over the walls and you know obviously
there's no phone there's no people
there's no nothing and then at this
point uh
what ended up happening was that the
daughter marion she actually said well
i'll get out of the car and i'll just
like stay here by the road uh so you can
have so the woman can fit in the car
because she wouldn't fit in there with
all the people in the back seat so she
because the you know the cabin was only
like a little way away so she's kind of
like just walking around on the road by
herself and the rest of them kind of go
back to this cabin
now so while uh frank and laura the mom
and dad are sort of exploring this cabin
looking for somebody or looking for
what's going on and uh the teenage son
of course because he's a teenage boy uh
wanders off in the woods to jerk off
literally
he's brought porn with him he's like
come prepared
for this [ __ ] for this journey and uh
so yeah so he's kind of uh disappeared
and then so this miss this mystery woman
and brad marion's boyfriend are left in
the car at which point brad like starts
talking to her and then she kind of
talks like because he asks her about the
baby and she says oh her name is amy and
then he's like she's like do you want to
hold her
and so he does
um but then he's like yeah um you know
how does your baby breathe with all that
uh blanket over their face
and you know what probably the answer to
that one is
so after that uh you know so everybody
starts freaking out about that and then
basically she ends up kind of like
taking off or like disappearing or
whatever so as the movie goes on there
they start driving down this road and
one thing that they notice is that one
they have had they have yet to pass
another car the only car that they
passed was the one that he almost hit
like when he almost fell asleep so they
haven't passed a car since then
they haven't seen any cross streets
they have seen
a sign
which points to a town called marcotte
but they have maps uh because this is
2003 they didn't have gps uh you know or
it wasn't widespread or whatever and
they have the maps and they're like yeah
uh there's no town called that like
around here
so they're trying to like come up with
ideas it's like you know why is this
road there's like nobody on it why are
there no cross streets why are there no
signs you know we should have found
something by now there should have been
a gas station so they're coming up with
all this all these different kind of
ideas where the most plausible one like
frank comes up with the idea he's like
oh well maybe this is like a military
road and it's like around some secret
military base and they don't really want
people on here we just got here on here
by accident and uh you know so that's
why
and then so they try to start to figure
out well if we stay on this road and if
indeed this town called marcotte is you
know is up ahead because that's all it
says is mark out with an arrow on it
doesn't see how far it is or anything
and he's like well if if we're following
this road which is going to the west uh
which they figure out he's like well
then we should get to the coast at least
like in 50 miles so it's like we can't
be that lost however uh the road just
keeps on going straight
and it doesn't seem like they're getting
anywhere and weirdly enough they also
pass the same sign that says marcotte
they just like keep passing it so
essentially they're in this kind of
purgatorial loop type of situation where
it's uh you know they've kind of gone
into the twilight zone you know like you
said because there's no there's no way
for them to get off the road
and another thing uh that's pretty
upsetting about this whole situation
is that uh pretty much every time they
stop the car
uh somebody ends up getting killed so
like the first time that they stop when
they go back to the cabin and the woman
in white is there
uh brad ends up getting killed
and he is uh essentially he's pretty
much like torn apart although they don't
really show that they only show like
part of it or it's it's implied or
suggested um i think like his severed
ear is shown or something like that and
then later on like linshay draws
something that looks like that so he's
like all torn up in pieces
and uh so the only other car on the road
that they see is this black hearse
and
what and so like they don't know where
brad went like after the woman in white
disappeared and then brad disappeared
and then this hearse goes by and then
they see brad in the back like being
like let me out let me out like out of
the back window and then like later on
they find him and he's all [ __ ] up and
dead so pretty much as they go along the
road some every now and then they have
to stop for whatever reason like one
time there's a baby carriage in the
middle of the road inexplicably and they
stop and then somebody ends up getting
killed and uh every time this black
hearse
goes by and the person gets
you know gets put in the hearse and then
like you find them later on and they're
all like [ __ ] up so that's
essentially the entire movie so honestly
the whole movie
you know 90 95 of the movie takes place
inside the car like while it's moving
and so it's a lot of interactions
between
the family and you'd think that that
would be
i don't know i just you'd think that
would be boring or it would get annoying
and it totally does not just because as
i said earlier all the actors in this
are so good that
you really get the sense that this is a
real family and they ha and they have
all these you know simmering resentments
against one another and it's all kind of
like coming out as
you know the situation gets worse and
worse you know like you know as it goes
on and like you know the family members
end up getting killed or dying in
horrible ways you know and they don't
know what's going on they don't know
where they are they don't understand why
they can't get off this road why it's
not going any place why they keep seeing
the same sign why it seems like they're
just like circling around you know in
this hellish sort of uh situation
uh so they're just getting like stressed
out and stressed out and all this stuff
starts coming out about
you know how uh maybe the teenage son
was uh was actually the product of an
affair that mom had and then you know it
turned out the dad was maybe having an
affairs as well turns out that marion is
pregnant and it's like you know the
sun's like using drugs and all this
other stuff so all this so as it's going
on like all of this stuff starts coming
out about the family but as i said it's
not
it's almost done like in a black comedy
kind of way and in that vein i think
that like ray wise and uh lin shay like
crush it in this movie they are so
good and you can tell
that i mean in this movie it totally
totally seems like they've been married
for 20 years and they just like loathe
each other but there's i mean they don't
loathe each other but it's like there's
a lot of uh resentments that have been
built up there and it's like a lot of
like passive aggressive kind of uh
comments and stuff that kind of get more
and more like overt as [ __ ] gets worse
and worse
and the thing that happens uh with one
of the family members getting killed
and
uh laura the mom you know lynn shay
hers her reaction to it she basically
just
wigs the [ __ ] out she almost kind of
like goes into
denial and then she starts doing all
this weird [ __ ] like like eating an
entire pie and like just saying all this
crazy [ __ ] and that part of it is just
like so good and it's just so
funny but it's also like kind of
horrifying funny you know what i mean so
it really does a good job of like
straddling this line between this like
really really like black humor and being
kind of like
i don't want to say sad but it's like
kind of tragic and horrific at the same
time because it's sort of like there's
scenes like that where that are just
kind of like i don't i don't necessarily
want to say goofy but are just kind of
like that are funny but like in a
blackly comic kind of way uh just
because the situation is so absurd and
bizarre that it's like they don't really
know how to react to it um but then
there's like when you know some of the
family members get killed there's
actually genuine
like you know emotion and like tragedy
and stuff like that there so it's like a
really um i think the movie really um
you know kind of tread that
that balance that tightrope like really
really well to a sense i don't i don't
know it's like it's hard for me to say i
guess you could call it a horror comedy
because it is funny
but
i don't know it's also kind of creepy
too there's like a lot of really
unsettling like i said it's more like an
unsettling
kind of thing then it's not gory and
it's not
you know there's not there's not any
jump scares really or any kind of like
horrific
imagery but just the situation
and the way that each of them reacts to
it and the way all of them
you know in a way it's kind of like you
wish that the family would i think
that's what kind of what the tragedy was
because ryan hollinger did a really good
um video about this a couple years back
and he said the tragedy of the movie was
that you know you would think that a
family that was this fragmented and if
they were in a situation like this it
would be better if they would all pull
together and try to figure out what was
going on and how to get out of the
situation but they don't do that they
pretty much all just react to it in
their own ways and become even more
fragmented and it's like really sad and
he was talking about like the ending
being really sad too which actually the
way he put it like when you think about
it it is like pretty [ __ ] sad now i
don't necessarily want to spoil the end
as i said what the description of it
that i gave
if you've seen a lot of twilight zone
type stuff or you've seen a lot of
horror movies like this you might be
able to figure out where it's going but
i will note that stay um through i can't
remember how far into the credits it is
but there is like a little bit of a
credits
uh sequence did is it i just watched the
[ __ ] yesterday and i i feel like the
credit started
yeah and then there's like a scene so
there is like a mid credit scene or a or
a credit scene uh you know in the middle
of the credits that
introduces ambiguity back into the story
because at the end of the story it sort
of like explains what was going on um
and you're like oh okay you know now i
get it but if you watch into the credits
there is like a little short scene in
there that as i said introduces the
ambiguity back into it i'm not sure if
the filmmakers put that in there because
they thought that the ending would piss
some people off um because they didn't
like that explanation or i'm not really
sure why or if that was their plan all
along i don't i can't i don't know what
to tell you but um
honestly i i think it's good either way
um as i said it's not the most original
twist if you want to call it that um you
know i have seen other things that have
been done like that but that doesn't
matter it's like i honestly i think that
i don't think it's necessarily you know
oh it's been done before or anything
like that but i just think like the
execution of it is so good and so
enjoyable that it doesn't really matter
and i actually kind of like that they
put that other scene in there so so it
kind of left you guessing it's like oh
well was that really the explanation or
did all that happen the way that you
thought that it happened and all this
other kind of stuff like i said i'm
really trying i'm trying not to spoil it
because i know a lot of people haven't
uh seen it even though it came out a
long time ago it came out in 2003 um but
i do feel like a lot of horror fans
haven't seen it and it's definitely a
really really good christmas horror film
it's not overtly christmas but they are
going to grandma's house for christmas
the whole back of the car is filled with
christmas presents and they do actually
you know when they get stuck along the
road they do actually utilize like some
of the stuff that they wrapped to take
to grandma's house and there's a kind of
a funny scene as i said earlier with
lynn shea and a
and a horrible sounding pie that she
made
um i think it's pumpkin and chocolate
and she's thinking which might be good i
don't know it's would it i don't know
i just they said it and then like the
teenager was like man that smells like
that smells like ass and i was just kind
of like i can't decide if pumpkin
chocolate pie would be good or not
probably not but
i don't know i don't see how it could be
that bad i don't know i'm thinking too
much about it probably but uh but yeah
so so it's christmasy in that sense uh
you know and they sing jingle bells and
[ __ ] like that while they're driving so
you know so if you've seen a lot of
christmas horror movies and you like
christmas horror movies and you want to
check out one that you maybe haven't
seen that's a little bit underrated a
little bit of a as i said one location
pretty much the whole thing takes place
inside the car um obviously they get out
of the car sometimes too for various
reasons um along this one road but it
pretty much takes place along this one
road the only time that they're not
on the road is when they're maybe like a
little bit in the woods or at that
little weird cabin like a time or two
and that's pretty much it but as i said
you don't need a big budget you don't
need
you know snazzy special effects you
don't need all that kind of stuff if you
have really good actors and a really
good concept and a really good script
and this definitely has all three of
those things so
please watch it uh for christmas i
actually love this movie i've seen it
three or four times at this point and i
just like it better each time um i just
love i love the characters you know what
i mean just their bickering is just like
so so funny to me and like just the the
crazy situations that that ensue and
like the way that that each of them like
reacts to the crazy situation uh is just
so so good to me and it's just like and
it's it's dark but it's also like really
funny and it's really kind of like my
sense of humor so i really really dig it
hopefully you will dig it as well if you
haven't seen it as i said uh i believe
you can watch it
i think if you have the imdb add-on for
amazon prime i think you can watch it on
there on there or you can watch it on 2b
for free or i think maybe maybe you can
rent it on youtube i'm not really sure
but honestly um i would go go to toby
and watch it um and it's it's just
really really fun and i think more
people should see it and it should be
up there with kind of like the classic
christmas horror movies uh definitely
and probably one that you should put in
your rotation uh every year around the
holiday and that will do it for this
christmas edition of my flickers of fear
merry christmas happy holidays and i
will see you on the next one bye